à la pointe du jour le bosquillon
bûcheron quitte la loge barak par la
planche petit pont qui enjambe le
ruisseau pour embûches et entreprendre
la coupe dans le breuil le bois il
retrouve en chemin les faux de
charbonnier le formiez sabotier le bal
haussier fabricant de balai et son ami
roulier débardeurs qui revient avec une
carotte et un chargement
je ne voulais pas faire un dictionnaire
je voulais faire des livres sur les
anciennes techniques du bois et de la
forêt en m'informant lisant des ouvrages
anciens je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait
tout un tas de mots dont moi je n'y
aurais complètement la signification et
j'ai commencé de les noter pour me
rappeler
et puis petit à petit je me suis pris au
jeu et je n'ai découvert bien sûr des
centaines puisque dans ce dictionnaire
est là autour de 6000 fils et petit-fils
de forestiers forestier lui même pierre
rousselin a réussi un coup de maître
un travail de dix années qui permet
désormais aux chercheurs de comprendre
le sens de certains mots qu'il trouve
dans les archives pendant 2000 ans notre
civilisation a été celle du bois elle a
généré des métiers des objets des usages
et avec eux des milliers de mots le
bouchonnier par exemple le bouchonner
fabriquer des bouchons
aujourd'hui on a des usines qui fait
avec les bouchons mais avant on avait
des artisans qui fabriquait les bouchons
le cendrier le cendrier eh bien ils
fabriquaient de la sambre parce qu'on
avait besoin de cendres mais un besoin
de cendres pour faire la lessive par
exemple
[Musique]
faux
ici le schlittage du nom de la luge la
schlitte qui permettait aux hommes de
sortir le bois là où les bleues ne
passait pas dans ce dictionnaire on
trouve également tous les maux liés au
flottage du bois dans les années 1850
paris consommer 1 millions de stères de
bois qui arrivait par la scène en
provenance du morvan sa mobilisé une
armée de monde autour de ce bois qui
partait du morvan par flottage qui
arrivait jusqu'à clamecy par flottage et
à clamecy ont retiré toutes ses bûches
de l'eau et on formait des radeaux
d'environ 200 stères de bois qui
partagent jusqu'à paris
il ya encore 150 ans c'est un monde qui
vivaient dans la forêt dans la grande
forêt de chaux au 13ème siècle on
engraissait 20000 bovins et entre 20 et
40 mille port donc la forêt elle n'était
pas du tout comme celles qu'on peut
connaître aujourd'hui c'était une forêt
qui était pâturer où il vivait
énormément de monde aujourd'hui la forêt
n'est plus un lieu de vie elle a
retrouvé sa vaste superficie du
moyen-âge environ 16 millions d'hectares
mais son avenir est incertain si les
métiers et les mots du bois ont disparu
avec les évolutions techniques les
arbres eux mêmes au moins certains
pourraient bien faire les frais du
changement climatique
sa menace principalement les grandes
forêts d'épicéas qui constituent les
massifs comme les ardennes et vosges le
jura les pyrénées le morvan bien sûr
chez nous et on sait que les épicéas
sont très fragiles ou manque d'eau on
n'est pas là merci de voir disparaître
des forêts entières des piscines
vraisemblablement dans un siècle un
siècle et demi en bourgogne nord une
forêt du type méditerranéenne
une évolution qui n'a jamais été vu dans
notre histoire
ça va très très vite
pour l'heure son dictionnaire achevée
pierre rousselin s'octroie volontiers sa
récompense favorite se promener en forêt
entre les arbres vivants et les mots
oubliés